[MUSIC PLAYING]
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Wow, thank you.
I'm truly excited to be
here at the end of, I think,
a remarkable day.
I see such energy in the room.
I can't believe you guys have
gone through a whole day.
And clearly it must have
been something that got
you inspired and invigorated.
So the theme of sharing
personal stories--
I'd like to share some
of my personal learnings
as I've made my way through
a pretty long career in tech.
And hopefully, some of it will
be good learning for you, too.
So now, like many of you in the
audience, I'm living my dream.
I mean, aren't we all?
Look at where we are.
Look at what we're doing.
This is what I always wanted
to do when I was young.
But I didn't account
for two things.
One, I didn't
realize how hard it
can be to be a woman
in tech, particularly
as you become more senior.
So it's going to get worse.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's all good.
And two, and because it's
going to get worse, or harder,
it's really important.
I've got to stop--
I realized I had to stop keeping
a score and grading myself.
You know what we do, right?
We are always up there grading
ourselves, giving ourselves
little pluses and minus points.
The reality is there will be
A-plus days and there will be
F-minus days--
you know, B-plus years
and lucky breaks.
This is continuous learning.
We're going to go through
the ups and downs.
It's not a series
of exams that we
need to get perfect grades on.
And I wish I knew
this at the start.
So I'm going to recount
two episodes in my life
and my career that
are pretty personal.
These were days--
these were two days,
and they were closer to
the F days than A-plus.
But they taught me some
really powerful lessons.
The first was several
years ago at Google.
I was the product lead of
a very successful project.
We'd had a ton of
impact, and I'd
been doing this
for several years.
And you know, things
were going great.
In a turn of events that
I didn't quite foresee,
a new business leader
was hired into the org.
And this person then
proceeded to hire
a product leader, so essentially
someone who would be my boss.
So on that day, with
very little warning,
I was asked to introduce this
new product leader to my team.
And as I was doing
so, I caught the eye
of two women on my team,
and the look of devastation,
because they could
see how shaken I was.
And that, just
catching their eyes
and seeing what they were
saying through their eyes
made it so much worse.
And I wanted to go home and cry.
But that night, I had agreed to
meet a group of women friends
after work, so I
soldiered on, and I
went to have dinner with them.
And one of them took
me aside and said,
Gayathri, someday
you'll thank him.
You'll thank Mr.--
I'm going to call him Mr. B--
for showing you that
it's time to leave.
And I did.
I left that team.
I survived.
And the two women in the
audience on my team--
but I'm looking at two women
in the audience as I say this--
they survived, and they thrived.
In fact, they're
both on their way
to becoming very senior
and accomplished leaders
in technology.
So I thank the
wisdom of my friend,
the one who gave me the
advice that it was time to go,
and the sadness in those women's
eyes, because they inspired
me to make the change,
to move forward,
and to continue to develop
myself as a leader.
The second episode
happened just last year.
And in this case, it was
just about a year ago.
I was working at a
new effort at Google,
and it had been two years,
and we saw great promise.
This was a new market.
We didn't really know
quite how to crack it,
but we knew when we did, it
would be kind of awesome.
But we hadn't launched
a significant product
or had impact.
And at that time, at Google
we run these annual surveys.
It's a 360-degree survey
where people on the team
give feedback to each other,
but also to their manager.
And my manager feedback
scores were terrible.
I mean, they were the worst--
I'll still never forget
opening them up and seeing
just how awful they were--
the worst I had ever
experienced in the almost decade
that I've been at Google.
And so when I got this
feedback, it hit me really hard,
because I'd spent--
I think like many
of you, as women, we
do spend a lot of our time
thinking about other people,
and we really sort of
strive to do the right thing
by our family, by our spouses,
by our children, by our team.
And so this felt very personal.
So later that evening, I met up
with my 21-year-old daughter,
and in a strange role reversal,
she asked me how my day was.
I mean, women, please ask
your mother how their day is.
We don't do that enough.
And of course, that was
not the best day for her
to ask that question, because
I just went on and on.
I went in, and she listened
to me, which was, again, also
a surprising change.
And then she asked me, what
are you going to do about it?
And I launched into a slew of
excuses, and she stopped me,
and she said, you're feeling
betrayed, aren't you?
I said yes.
And she said, but are you
going to ask your team
why they feel this way?
And I realized then that I
was making this about myself.
It was my own baggage.
I was feeling sorry for myself.
I felt like, how could this
happen to me, when I'm so good,
instead of really
considering the feedback
and considering what I needed
to do to fix the situation.
So why am I sharing all this?
I mean, these were two of the--
I've had some pretty awesome
days, but these were hard days.
Well, firstly to show
you that it never ends.
It doesn't-- the hard knocks,
the questioning, the mistakes,
and the learning.
In the first episode, I
realized that even though I
was doing my work, I
really hadn't understood
the context of the organization,
which is very, very important.
And sometimes women
in particular, we
get our little heads
down and we're just
doing the right
thing, and we forget
that there is a
context around us that
really needs to be considered.
And the second--
I had not invested in
really understanding
how my team was
being impacted as I
was striving to get
us to a goal post that
kept getting pushed out.
I wasn't really looking around
and actually understanding,
trying to make sense of what
was happening to the people who
were with me on that journey.
So there was definitely some
personal learning for me
in both these cases.
But at those key moments, I
also found incredible support
and strength in the
women around me--
my friends, my team, and
now even my daughter.
They showed me with clear eyes--
they saw me with clear eyes.
They felt my pain, and
they also showed me
that there was a way out of it.
Now, I know we all have
things we need to do
as we learn on our journey.
But I feel at the same time
it's really important for us
to take the time and make
a special effort to help
women around us
through their journeys.
There's real power
in this, as I found.
And I have seen three simple
things that I try to do.
They're really small.
They don't really
take much time.
But I find them--
I find that these
are really important.
When I see women going
through a rough patch,
I make the time
to listen to them.
I make the time to
sort of understand
what they're going
through and be
a sounding block or an advisor.
The second is, it's sort of--
I think every one of you has
experienced this, very likely,
in some fashion or the other.
In large meetings,
when women talk,
sometimes they don't
often feel heard.
I find it really simple,
but really powerful,
to reinforce what
another woman said.
Oh, Amy, that was a great idea,
following up on what she said.
And just having
someone reinforce
that can be really powerful.
It's so simple to do.
And finally, when women
question themselves,
as we all do, as I did,
if they're good enough
or whether they're an
admissions mistake,
I tell them to get
over it and own it.
Own the work.
Own where you are.
Own your mistakes, and
own the path forward.
And it's really important
for us to get that counsel,
particularly when we're
starting to feel like we are--
we're not doing what, you know--
when things aren't working.
We're actually in a really
good place for a reason.
All of you are here
for a very good reason.
It wasn't a glitch in
Google's selection process.
But there's a fourth.
I get myself back up from
whatever pit I've fallen into.
I mean, those two
experiences that I recounted,
they ended up in making
me make some changes that
were pretty significant.
But they also sort
of made me realize
that this was not just something
that I needed to do for myself.
Particularly as I've
sort of, over the years,
as I've become older
and more senior,
I found that there are several
younger, more junior women who
look up to me to
see what I'm doing.
When I bounce back, they know
that it's just as hard for me
as it is for them, and
that they can do it too.
So really, what we do
for ourselves is a gift
we give other women.
That's the biggest learning
I've had in my life in tech.
But now there's so
much more we can do.
All of you in this room,
think about the power
you have-- the networking,
the connections you can build,
that we can do for each other.
We'll never stop
having those bad days.
I'm pretty sure I'm going
to have quite a few more
as I continue on my journey.
But let's aim to be that leader
at whatever level, at whatever
stage, who's there
to wipe the tears
and offer a glimpse
of the road ahead,
and who can show
that it can be done,
that really anything
is possible.
So with that, I
want to thank you.
I hope you take
something out of it.
But really, more
importantly, I hope
you take that the real power
that comes out of all this
is the power within you,
and every one of you,
and the power we have in
really bringing the best out
of each other forward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]